we've spent a lot of time over the last
two days in this room talking about
really some pretty remarkable effects
that AI in particular is having on how
companies are thinking about uh their
their path forward uh a as an investor
uh how significant and as an as a
economic historian how significant is
this technology I think it's hugely a
significant and I'm not I'm not just
starting on it um I found like 25 years
ago I started uh writing down my
principles in words and then they became
encoded in algorithms we built systems
decision-making computerized
decisionmaking systems and there was a
great power and I've watched the whole
Arc of this and I know the power it it
is stupid it is archaic for people to
think that decision making just in their
heads is going to be good there has to
be a part partnership between what's in
your heads and what is what the computer
does because it's so much powerful in so
many other ways so I think it's part of
the whole evolutionary process